uh
guidelines thank you
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is
carried
right that takes us on to declaration of
counsel at conflicts of interest are
there any new conflicts that councillors
wish to declare this afternoon or ones
that particularly relate
to the agenda that we're discussing
there's not thank you so i'm sure that
if anything arises you will
make sure that we're aware of any
potential conflict there
so beginning with uh confirmation of
minutes
we have three sets of minutes to confirm
uh first one is the minutes of the
ordinary media council held on tuesday
14 september would somebody like to move
that be a true and correct record
move councillor dixon dog signer
councillor
reed thank you
are there any alterations required to
that record or not i'll put the motion
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
uh confirmation of the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting of council held on
wednesday 22 september
would somebody like to move that that be
seen as a true and correct record
council grant thank you
do you have a segment for that
councilor phillips thank you
are there any alterations required to
that record
they're not i'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
thank you councillors
and confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting of the community strategy
committee held on wednesday 22 september
somebody like to move that be seen as a
true and correct record councillor reed
thank you diver seconder for that
councillor uh bulger thank you
all those in favor please or is there
any alteration there's not
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried so any
recommendations contained within that
report
somebody like to move that they'd be um
confirmed
counselor hosted
is this the point we get an opportunity
to discuss those or is it coming
it's probably just it's just a hardy
annual of mine
um around um
pre pre-determining what the annual plan
contains so it items
in strategy
um i would prefer and i'll be bid to
move the the recommendations provided
that say
that the funding sort is approved via
the annual plan process
and the second item is
of 27 440 is for consideration in the
22-23 annual plan often we find
ourselves an annual plan with a list of
items that we've already approved and no
no opportunity to discuss so
um no no issues with with the with the
strategy just think the funding needs to
be
managed at the annual plan time
okay
so just for my clarity you're
making a change to the third
recommendation is that right so the
second recommendation that the event
strategy be approved and implemented um
with funding aspects to be considered at
future annual plans
in that the third item that funding to
the value of 27440
be included and
included ed for consideration in the
22-23 annual plan
okay so you're moving
[Music]
um yes
okay do i have uh
a seconder for that
council grant is that right
you worship i'll like a comment from the
chief executive particularly around the
27k
so
i'll just i'll um i'll open it up to the
chief executive now i just needed to get
a second off of that before we go any
further so i take the point that you're
making um
cliff and it has been seconded by
councillor brown
um
and steve just the ramifications of that
alteration do you want to make a comment
on that
yeah thank you worship uh no no real
issues i completely understand where
council heisted's coming from and and to
fear he as he said he has raised this
concern before the issue really is uh
you're you're endorsing it in isolation
and you obviously think it's a good idea
and we all do
but i also take the point that you're
doing so not knowing what other
priorities may present themselves
and you may be forced to have to reorder
those priorities
if there are
more bigger ticket items that you didn't
expect that come through
the next few months in preparation for
next year's draft and your plan so just
still this amendment in my view your
worship
still
does justice to the spirit of the
committee's
thinking but also leaves you some room
to maneuver should some unexpected
circumstances arise between now and
probably april next year when we do our
draft and your plan
so councillor mcphail is chair of the
committee you've got your hand up
uh yes that's just three questions a
comment uh am i coming through clearly
yep well there is clarisse
um yeah i don't have an issue with what
uh council high state has stated there
um it is one of those
uh methods that we have discussed
bringing um the the committee working
committees recommendations to council um
and we have workshopped um around that
value there and it is accepted that um
obviously endorsing an isolationist
as a ceo uh indicates there could be
other priorities so
i think it's around the fact that when
we are bringing these matters through
from the uh other committees that we
ensure that we are
applying the correct um
correct application so it does fit
within that annual plan i know that we
did
when that amount was discussed that we
did
uh look at
that it was still being brought to
the main council for um uh
recommendation and or endorsement or
application
uh that's why any comment
okay great thank you uh any other
comments um
if not
um i'll put the motion
uh all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried are there
any other operations required to the
recommendations contained within that
report
there's not
okay oh councillor highset
no not not a change but i just think the
um
item three the over 80s
is that has that got the mileage it
should have in terms of public but
that's a very very good initiative of
this committee and great for the
community like where i've been asleep at
the wheel i just haven't seen too much
of that in the media um the council
doing good work and the committee doing
good work
i think we can always get more more
profile but i'm sure that it has been
out there maybe you just don't meet the
age profile counselor hosting i don't
know
your worship potentially they could be a
new ambassador or a patron of the
service
and the counselor that's wanting to
champion its publicity
can i
could i possibly assist
counselor hosted there
we did have a um article or there was a
spread or uh ready for living had a
spread in the ensign which featured a
story about it and we just have held off
pushing it out until we got the disks
created in the paperwork and all the
process behind it so
now that we can once we get those done
we'll be pressing go on any publicity
okay right so that brings us back to the
adoption of that
particular committee with the one change
so with somebody like
we
yeah when somebody like to move um
the adoption of the
recommendations contained with it within
the community strategy committee
including the change that we've just
made
move council phillips signature council
dixon thank you
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors i think that brings us to
the end of the minutes that we need to
um
consider uh and brings us on to urgent
light business is there any urgent late
business that we need to be
discussing today
it's not thank you
and rural halls and domains subcommittee
we have a recommendation
uh or two recommendations of the
meeting of that particular committee
that the minutes be received and the
recommendations contained within the
minutes be ratified would somebody like
to move
that that be confirmed
councillor guardon
and sigma council grant thank you
any questions or comment council
mcfarlane you've got your hand up no
it's gone
counselor got on
just one thing to notice the time
five minutes flat
what is she in starting times
you suggesting that's good or bad
okay yeah good point
okay um put the motion all those in
favor from their eye
against the motion was carried thank you
right so that brings us on to
uh symmetry policy
and we have a um
an item here that's been um
raised in uh response to a letter that's
come from um this is margaret puller
with regard to
uh booking cemetery spots at the top or
our cemetery and we have a report from
our um a man on the spot keith mcrobe
and i think that outlines exactly
the way forward certainly in my mind
keith but do you want to make any
comment uh on this at this point
uh through through your worship um
like i think the um the committee or
sorry the um
the trust involved with pukarao um it's
very much a community-based group and
they're quite an active
group uh lead led by margaret puller and
uh it is essentially uh i guess most of
the group is sort of the descendants of
the pillars of the trapski's and um so
they've had a long history
with with that particular site
and uh
they uh
you know i guess they're keen to
to to uh open the opportunities to uh
some of their descendants and family
members um going forward really so it's
it's a bit of a
diversion away from our from our policy
but um
it's it's quite a different situation to
uh
the three main symmetries really and um
so that's
yeah i think it's got to be considered
on that basis too really
thank you keith steve do you want to
make any comment before i open it for
discussion no one find your issue
i know um so open for discussion
counselors and or recommendation which
is contained on page 28
um so uh council read
i'm happy to
move the recommendation you worship i
think this group
have worked really hard they're made
lots of changes out there in a very
positive way and i
i agree with the recommendation i'm
quite happy to move it all right do i
have a signature for that
uh council graham thank you
uh right
councillor hosted then councillor dixon
yeah just through your worship i just
have a question for keith what does
controlled pre-purchase mean just the
definition of control i wasn't familiar
with that just curious
oh okay i think
with our main policy we've got um
basically uh if a deceased
if we
have a deceased person
if their family can currently
book an adjoining plot so that that's a
controlled situation really and and i i
i think that the risk if you would open
this up with all the cemeteries
we would have lots of
pre-purchase sites and um
it would it would be a really difficult
situation to manage really so um
and and i think going back in time i
think was an issue
uh a few years ago where um
a burial was took place on a site that
had been
pre-sold and um
the mechanism wasn't in place to kind of
manage that so it becomes a pretty
embarrassing situation really so
okay so so controlled means specific to
book around
that's that's
in the sense yeah thank you yeah
and the this whole policy we're talking
about now is specific to the growth as
well yeah
okay councillor dixon then council grant
thank you worship i'd just like to say
that i do support the proposal of the
pokhara trust as well because i feel it
sits outside here
um
controlled
at present policy
and
they do they have looked after that
cemetery particularly well and done a
lot of work out there
just offering my support
thank you
council grant
thanks your worship uh yeah i'm the same
as uh the two previous councillors so
it's it's a
lovely letter by margaret and they have
done a huge amount of work uh also good
uh on behalf of
or to keith the fact that uh there is
going to be a full report coming to
council at some stage
um regarding the other uh cemeteries in
our district there was a few years ago
an issue in the in the uh eastern
cemetery where um
a young person was
died accidentally
and his parents wanted to buy a plot
either side of them
the policy didn't allow that but we
worked through that one and that was
that was a one-off situation but
i'm guessing here that
next year when this
report comes to council with all the
different
scenarios and also your cultural things
that may happen
yeah
we may have to change one or two things
but no i'll fully support this one
right okay is there any other counselors
wish to make any comment does not i'll
put the motion all those in favor please
say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
uh thank you councillors that brings us
on to item seven and the sport new
zealand rural travel fund and the
allocation of funding
for this particular period and the
recommendation is that the report be
received do i have a mover for that
that recommendation
uh councillor hosted of a secondary
council davis thank you
it's open for discussion is there any
discussion from councillors on that
questions there's not i'll put the
motion all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
um
right a item eight report on the
abatement notice received for school
stormwater discharge into falconer creek
and a draft storm water by lawyer
something of quite a bit of substance
and
i'll ask for comment um firstly from the
chief executive and then from the
three waters asset manager if i can on
the way forward with this particular
issue so steve
yeah thanks your worship i'll defer in
the main to
matt bayless for three waters manager
but um it's clear with the abatement
notice issued upon us that uh the
existing
framework we have to dealing with this
is inadequate and
whilst the um environment south and said
we want you to put in place a policy
framework to manage these discharges our
analysis
uh has come to the conclusion that
really a bylaw which has some uh teeth
in terms of if
we get to that point a potential
prosecution
will hopefully ensure
compliance and improvements that we want
to see
on these properties because to be candid
the council at the moment is a bit of
like a sitting duck it's receiving
discharges from properties
and has no meaningful way of controlling
it yet is a sitting duck in terms of
facing the regulatory might environment
southland
which of course has been responding to
complaints about discharges into the
thank you river much
yeah thank you and through
your worship um yeah so
um
obviously we received an abatement
notice earlier this year regarding the
discharge into falcon creek um and as a
result of that we've done quite a bit of
work
um
[Music]
understand the issue um and doing a bit
of research into how we can manage the
short things
since then um and as i think steve
covered off and we think that a boiler
is required to manage this um
i guess
stormwater quality is probably a bit of
a new space that we're moving into in
terms of improving it
[Music]
and
predominantly historically the focus has
been more on wastewater discharges
but stormwater is becoming more and more
of a priority
[Music]
and um yeah i guess the research that
we've found is that
and in that particular catchment um
there's no one particular
property that's that's causing issues
it's multiple properties
um and i guess
what we're um our understanding is that
the the full removal of the suspended
solids and the discharge is going to be
quite a challenging
process
um and it could potentially require
multiple treatment steps um to do that
so i think it's going to be a bit of a
approach and um you know we're going to
have to
target the
the worst areas first
and and then as we move along um the
quality and the discharge will slowly
get better
um
we do also think that there's a need to
look at our existing discharge consent
um some of the conditions in there are
quite onerous and potentially um
very difficult to achieve
um so we think there's value in
revisiting that and seeing if we can't
get something
we certainly still need to make
improvements um they might be sort of
more realistically achievable if we can
get them amended
thank you happy to take any questions
thank you uh matt um and obviously he's
going to have um quite a change in the
way that we manage water in that
particular catchment
and
i think it's fairly obvious that it does
need to be changed so
whether it's the right way to go forward
i guess is the real
issue for us now and what's being
proposed here
is subject consultation
so i think from right and thinking matt
it's a month's consultation is that
right for um landowners and affected you
people in that
catchment to
to
consult and
let us know their their feelings
um so just wondering about timing for
that consultation process
if this was to be adopted today is the
way forward
what would the consultation process look
like in i'm just in mind of
how christmas is not too far away from
where we're at now
and everybody gets pretty busy at that
time so i think it is a reasonably
important
process that we're embarking on here and
we need to give people
as much opportunities we can
uh to have him put into that so i'm not
sure whether you're the right person to
answer that question man or whether
steve is
through your worship um you know i can
answer a couple of those questions and i
might pass the communications manager as
well um because we have had some
discussions around it
um
so i guess the first point is um the
bylaw will apply to um
the entire
urban networks of both gore and matara
so
in terms of consultation we'll be
consulting with
the entire urban area
although in saying that obviously the
issue that we have at the moment is in
that feltner road catchment so they'll
be sort of the higher priority
properties
in terms of applying the buy law
and you know i have had a discussion
with the communications manager
and we're thinking
that we'd have the consultation period
which is 20 working days as a minimum
prior to christmas um potentially with
it closing
sort of early or mid-december um and
then if there was a requirement for a
hearing we would have that
um
probably late january or something like
that
there aren't
any particular time pressures around the
consultation so if there was a
preference to delay at all until the new
year then we could potentially do that
um
yeah sonia did you have anything you
wanted to add there
uh through the chair thank you matt um
he's right we we could depending on what
the council prefers obviously people
won't be engaging with us um
second week december onwards to be fair
um so we would need to do the community
consultation we'll ask for school for
submissions in november
finding that you're probably looking at
um
if council wanted to i think february
because january most people are
disengaged or still on holiday so you
would carry out your
submission process february with a
hearing after that
thank you
okay um
uh in regards to
would it not be a district-wide um bylaw
because there is waikaka and could
possibly affect mandela in some aspects
too
for your worship yeah yes sorry neville
you're correct yeah so it also applies
to
uh the stormwater networks in waikaka
mandeville and pokhara
so it's wherever we've got a reticulated
stormwater network
thanks for the clarification
um councillor heister
thank you yeah thank you worship i i
agree with the recommendation but i'm
just reflecting on what's happening in
the rural community with catchment
groups and wonder on a more positive
note whether there's an opportunity for
the council to
to work with
industry or owners in that area there's
some quite large scale graveled
team of landowners in the area to
facilitate
the formation of a landowner-led
catchment group i think that could be a
positive
step the council could take to to bring
out some leadership
as you know as these businesses embark
on the on the resolution of what they
have to do in that area so
if there was a will i'd be quite keen to
see that incorporated in the
recommendation
very good idea thanks for raising that
bread i think it's um excellent shall i
move it
into the recommendation at the end of
the discussion
um glennis
thank you worship i was i was just
watching um clarity around whether it's
school district council's responsibility
to mitigate sediment from
water streams
from private property because i
understood it was environment
southland's role
through your worship
um so where
a property discharges into
our reticulated stormwater network
we hold the resource consent for the
resulting discharge into the environment
so it becomes our responsibility to
manage um any private property
discharging into that network
[Music]
that's different to
um a
a property that is discharging directly
to the environment from their property
and that would be an environment
southland process to manage
okay thank you and i was also wondering
um why it's not practical to sample the
water up streaming downstream of their
um
sump guards
is it cost or
essentially
it's
i guess it's costly there's no
sample points um so
it would be a matter of
installing dedicated
um sampling points and access points
which
while you could do it it would be very
costly to do
um per sum yeah so
i guess essentially it comes down to
cost yeah
thank you
okay um
counselor
garden and then councilman farm
just a question for matt through your
worship
how does this apply to our gravel roads
in the urban area and the rural area um
we have to car seal existing gravel
roads in the urban area or going forward
or what's going to happen there
through your worship yes so
i guess this
bylaw doesn't specifically apply to it
[Music]
but
i guess the principles do and i'm not
sure how environment southland plan on
tackling that issue
but
potentially
it is going to become an issue
um
yeah so i'm not
sure exactly how it's going to be
handled going forward
okay um
council mcphail
councilman you've still got your hand up
it's just uh through russia
i think council guidelines cover off
what i was going to say but
we are i do support um
obviously we need to do something here
but we're obviously in the situation of
creating a bylaw because we've breached
a law where we've
been served with abatement and we create
another bylaw
where if it gets breached we make um a
person will be served on an abatement so
it's um probably law making at its best
and it is required
uh which leads on to the fact that i
think council the high stakes discussion
around what we use as groups um and any
assistance that we can give there's some
very very um strong groups particularly
in the rural areas um
around uh things that can improve and i
think we could apply that to that
industrially or any assistance that we
could uh come through and i know through
the community strategies group we've had
presentations from some working groups
very close to the core boundary there
which we may be able to facilitate
further
thank you counselor
um
council bulger
yeah i just want a little bit of clarity
from matt
the uh
the photograph shows uh problems with
sediment into forklift creek
so as some of our stormwater
system discharges in the faulkner creek
uh and also another question if
there is a
a business which uh could be
contributing to that
um
how would we you know if we had
knowledge of that i'd imagine we'd have
to approach approach them and have them
to try and do something inside there
inside their boundary
thank you
through your worship yeah so um i guess
um that's your first question
um yeah so the sampling that we have
have done has shown that um
there's quite an increase in sediment um
and felt in the creek
um
downstream of our stormwater discharge
points compared to upstream um so
you know the evidence is quite clear
that there is
sediment coming from our discharge into
into feldman creek
the second part of your question
yeah so where there are
specific properties
discharging
a significant amount of sediment into
the into the stormwater we'd work with
with those property owners
to to come to a solution
i suspect each
property will the solution for each
property could be different um and
you know there's a number of different
approaches that you can take to to
manage the sediment runoff and so it'll
be about finding a solution that fits
each individual property
rather than a one size fits all
still another question
that sedimentation is they're coming
from air roading the equipment because
the the reports highlighted that war is
also coming from businesses who are
discharging into the wastewater system
that goes into their stormwater
were they separate
through your worship
so it's as a combination of both
um
we
the
i suspect the the large majority of it
is coming from private property
but there is certainly a component that
is coming from
our road reserve as well
i
think i possibly can help you somewhere
i'll have a chat to you offline
all right okay thanks
okay um
thanks your worship yeah uh just sort of
answering counselor bulger's last
question is there is a large area of
businesses in that region that don't
have hard seal
and
during heavy rain it just turns to mud
and there's quite a few of them and the
there's there's
in and around that area and that's your
major issue i believe uh and this report
has alluded to that
so that's yeah it's it's a case of
either uh
you know the report is is uh pretty
pretty uh
substantial in the fact that it tells us
it gives us a uh
a way forward
so
okay so you're moving the recommendation
do you include the um the idea that
councillor heisted had with regard to
working with landowners to form a
catchment group yeah a hundred percent i
mean uh you could you can and that's a
brilliant idea by council hosted it's uh
you would form a
um
a commercial instead of a you know uh
because there is there is one for the
area of the rural ratepayers uh if you
formed a commercial uh
or urban area for because a lot of those
guys and uh one of the companies in
there that maybe one of your biggest
players is a transport operator so you
know
they may be able to solve quite a few
their own problems
okay thank you um
your worship the
transport operator comes under
considerable scrutiny from environment
southland because they're a federalized
store
and they've had inspections ad nauseum
in the past so
i'm not sure that um
or i'm confident
that they are containing their own
uh potential contribution on time
okay take that point um
we have a seconder for the amended set
of motions
counselor heisted thank you
um
okay councils uh is there any further
comment before i put those motions
promotions always in favor please say
aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councils
uh
that's the ground
yeah with your worship
um
just before um
that that's been moved but we haven't
actually said about the um
the time frame to go out for submissions
we've sort of confirmed that and and i
believe uh
matt and sonia were sort of um asking
the council i i believe it should be
held off to february uh it's now october
by the time you get it ready it'll be
november november a lot of businesses in
that area will be gearing up flat out
doing everything before they can
to to finish before christmas so i think
february would be a more suitable time
so just a question
with regard to
the attitude of the regulator if we were
to put this off for another three months
and i'm not sure who's going to answer
that either matt or or steve
uh through your worship um so the the
abatement notice requires us to prepare
the appropriate policy framework ready
for consultation by january 2022
so we would be meeting that requirement
um obviously that be keen for us to get
things underway earlier but i don't see
too much of an issue delaying it
i think that makes sense everybody
comfortable with that approach
okay i'll see a lot of modding thanks
brings us on to uh our next item which
is uh
one that seems to be on every agenda um
doesn't matter where you are these days
it seems to be on every agenda and
that's a three water reform update and
we have an update from the chief
executive
uh which also includes a letter that's
gone from this council to the minister
and i understand the minister will be
making some recommendations to cabinet
if not
um
steve do you want to make any coming
i really worship i think it's i all i
hope is that the letter uh suitably
reflects the council's
um
mood and concerns at the last meeting
and as you said you worship we wait now
with interest the government's response
which we're told is uh expected by the
end of this month
okay
any comments or questions from
councillors with regard to three waters
council read
thank you your worship i'd just like to
mention that um
given all the information that
councillors have been inundated with and
the workshopping that we've done around
this
um i think the ratepayers of the
district can be assured that the letter
that went to minister mahuta
was quite concise and clear in our
opinion of the three waters reform
and i just think if they really want to
read all of it in detail they'll find it
on our council's website and um it was a
good letter
okay
so would somebody like to
move the recommendation then the middle
of the letter um be noted and endorsed
move
second
thank you
do you further comment on that one
there's not i'll put the motion all
those in favor please say hi
against the motion just carry thank you
councils
uh and we have a
report here with regard to health and
safety um
a uh report from
susan do you want to make any comment to
this susan
i've got nothing further to add your
worship thank you okay thank you
all right i think it's reasonably
straightforward
um would somebody like to move that
they've been received
councillor bulger secondary for that
please council grant thank you
all those in favor please stay on
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
um and we have
one final item of business on the open
part of this agenda and that is the
issuing of a staff warrant and
authorization
and that's coming from the human
resource manager do you want to make any
comment
to this one susan i guess reasonably
straightforward
yes it is your worship it's just
something that um we're required to
issue the staff member with so that he
can carry out his enforcement or
compliance duties as part of his role
okay
thank you
open for discussion
and or recommendation
yeah i'm happy to move that
recommendation you worship
counselor guarding thank you
all those in favor please say aye
okay emotions carried thank you
councillors so that's
to the end of the open section of the
council
business for today
uh we now move into um
excluded uh public excluded session um
which will be discussing
matters such as confirmation and other
business
uh relating to things such as the
community networking trust
um land purchase for treatment water
treatment update minutes the audit and
risk committee uh and uh deloitte
findings
would somebody like to move that we're
going to committee please
move council bulger got a secondary